et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
nicolas bay bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nos députés
européens vous êtes vice-président du
groupe identité démocratie au parlement
européen c'est le groupe dans lequel
siègent les députés du rassemblement
national dont vous faites partie
et puis vous êtes également candidat aux
régionales en normandie on va parler
tout ça on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par stéphane bern
et bonjour stéphane bonjour il dirige le
bureau parisien du journal ouest france
on commence par le terrorisme nicolas
bay puisqu'un projet de loi pour
renforcer la lutte contre le terrorisme
a donc été présenté hier en conseil des
ministres il ya des mesures notamment
pour renforcer le suivi des terroristes
pour améliorer le renseignement est ce
que ce sont des mesures que le
rassemblement national votera pas avoir
gardé exactement le détail des mesures
mais vous savez c'est le quinzième
textes liés au terrorisme qui est qui
passe à l'assemblée nationale depuis
et finalement on multiplie comme ça les
initiatives législatives des lois un peu
de communication des lois un peu de
circonstances souvent elles sont ensuite
peu ou pas appliquées et cela révèle pas
toujours efficace là que ce texte nous
dit on voit on va augmenter les
contrôles sur internet
bon c'est très bien mais il faudrait
peut-être commencer par au moins
améliorer le contrôle aux frontières
parce que le sujet central du terrorisme
et de tous les actes terroristes qui ont
frappé la france depuis un an
c'est la question de l'immigration est
donc bien sûr plein départ et du type de
l'autre faute d'accord par exemple très
concret de celui qui a frappé qui a tué
sept fonctionnaires de police à
rambouillet il est entré illégalement en
france en toute impunité il s'est
maintenu disant illégalement en france
au vert aux vertus des circulaires valls
il a été régularisée quand il est
régularisée en 2019 et bien sûr son
compte facebook
public 1 personnels et publics
parfaitement accessible il y a il est
truffé de références islamistes c'est à
dire qu'il est régularisée alors qu'on
n'a même pas pris la peine de taper son
nom dans le moteur de recherche et de
regarder son compte facebook et donc on
voit bien que donc ce n'est pas en
créant une loi supplémentaire
c'est ce que je mange
cette fois elle vise à améliorer le
contrôle notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux via des algorithmes est-ce que
du coup vous dites c'est une bonne chose
non mais ce qui est invraisemblable
c'est que cette personne soit
régularisée sans que ce contrôle ne soit
pas effectuée par l'administration alors
ensuite qu'on donne des moyens
supplémentaires à la police aux
enquêteurs a dit qu'alizé qui sera qu'il
terrorisme bien sûr tout tant mieux mais
on voit bien qu'il ya tellement de
défaillance à tous les étages dans le
contrôle des frontières
ensuite dans l'octroi des titres de
séjour puis dans la même dans les
naturalisations parce que si il avait
commis son attentat dans deux ou trois
ans et bien entre temps il avait
peut-être été naturalisés et d'ailleurs
vous certains de vos confrères un
concert nous à lundi à bat regardez
c'est un français alors qu'en réalité
eh bien il a toujours détesté la france
mais il aura profité du laxisme et la
généralité la france et qu'on concernant
le suivi des des français pour le coup
qui ont participé à des actes de
terroristes qui ont été condamnés à
plusieurs années et qui vont sortir donc
le renforcement des mesures de suivi la
sortie de prison ça c'est quand même
c'est quand même intéressant nécessaire
notamment pour tout ce qu'ils ont pu
être condamnés pour des actes dans les
années 90 il a quand même beaucoup qui
sont libérables aujourd'hui oui et puis
il faut les suivre il y en a même qui
sont cons été condamné plus récemment
mais qui sont condamnés à des peines
légères parce que souvent les exactions
ont été commises en civil se passe
encore suffisamment d'éléments matériels
ce qui leur pose un énorme problème
parce qu'en réalité on les laisse
revenir facilement sur notre territoire
on dit vous inquiétez pas on les
judiciarise c'est à dire qu'on les ronds
les on l'aimé en préventive ensuite on
l'est on les condamne mais à des peines
qui sont souvent légères qui sont pas
totalement appliquée et du coup quelques
les années plus tard ils sont là dessus
il n'a pas besoin de re légiférer je
vais je dis pas qu'il faut pas légiférer
il assemble des dispositions
législatives à améliorer mais je pense
que le problème central centrale c'est
la question du laxisme migratoires tous
les attentats commis en france depuis un
an l'ont été par des étrangers
romans sur isère c'est un soudanais le
deuxième attentat contre charlie hebdo
c'est un pakistanais l'assassin de
samuel pâtir conflans sainte honorine
c'est un tchétchène la basilique de nice
c'est un tunisien l'a à nouveau à
rambouillet saint tunisiens clandestins
donc quand est-ce qu'on arrête quand
est-ce qu'on arrête de laisser entrer en
france des dizaines de mille clandestins
chaque année et qui est qu'on accorde en
tout 400 mille entrées sur le territoire
national
270 mille titres de séjour cent vingt
mille ou cent trente mille demandeurs
d'asile et des attentats qui ont été
commis par des gens qui étaient français
et c'est ce que je vous dit de faire
la plupart enfin même la totalité ils
sont français soit en vertu du droit du
sol soit pas parce qu'ils ont obtenu une
naturalisation
après être entré y compris parfois et
d'entrer clandestinement c'est à dire
qu'en réalité ça pose le problème du
code de la nationalité il faut réformer
le code de la nationalité
aujourd'hui la nationalité française on
la distribuer comme des petits pains et
le résultat c'est que des gens qui
détestent la france qu'on fait aucun
effort d'assimilation et qui parfois se
retourne contre notre pays en commun en
commettant des attentats et bien peuvent
bénéficier peuvent rester enfant en
train en france resté en france être
régularisés puis naturalisé est ce qu'on
continue comme ça c'est ça le sujet
central
comme toujours c'est une loi terroristes
et puis une autre dans 18 mois
puisqu'elles émanent tous les 18 mois
mais ça ne réglera rien du problème le
problème ça va sinon on est pragmatique
s'il ya des dispositions de cette loi
qui sont plutôt bonnes tout en bon sens
sont les vôtres a sans aucun problème
mais on dit simplement que c'est pas ça
qui suffira à résoudre le problème voilà
ce que j'aimerais insister mais vous
avez quand même un certain nombre de
français ils sont nombreux qui sont
d'origine française parfois issus de
familles catholiques qui sont nés en
france qui sont parfaitement intégrés et
qui se sont radicalisées si je vous
parle de lionel dumont et medi clinic
les frères klein il ya quand même
beaucoup d'exemples ce n'est pas que
liés à l'immigration est
presqu'exclusivement liée à
l'immigration qu'on va regarder tous les
attentats commis depuis charlie hebdo
c'est ils sont tous immigrés issus de
l'immigration car parfois il ya des îles
ont un parent parents français etc
il ya des nuances mais il ya aussi des
cas où il ya deux par enveloppes et des
gens parfaitement intègre également ses
origines étrangères
et puis c'est le problème en effet de
l'islamisme en france ça c'est vrai vous
avez raison il ya pas qu en aval du
problème migratoire et ipad
on a laissé prospérer le communautarisme
et l'islamisme dans notre pays est
aujourd'hui on le voit et hommes des
exemples tous les jours des centaines et
des centaines de mosquées tenues par les
radicaux comment se fait-il que ne soit
pas fermé des imams radicaliser comment
se fait-il qu'ils ne soient pas expulsés
des associations
des fermetures de mosquées cette loi
elle vit c'est encore le montre le
marginal et leurs dépendances
marginalement vous avez six ou sept
mosquées qui ont été fermées et la
plupart d'ailleurs elles sont arrivées
ouverte quelques mois après avec les
mêmes fidèles au même endroit avec les
mêmes prêcheur et donc évidemment on
aura le même résultat la sortie on voit
bien qu'il n'ya pas une volonté
politique d'éradiquer l'islamisme dans
notre pays et il veut et pour éradiquer
l'islamisme il faut en finir avec
l'islam au clientélisme c'est à dire la
veulerie la lâcheté de ceux des pouvoirs
publics locaux de certains maires qui
achètent la paix civile dans leur
commune ou achètent les voix des futures
élections en faisant en étant
extrêmement bienveillant avec des avec
des des musulmans prétendu modèle qui ne
le sont pas du tout un mot enfin 2-2
question d'ailleurs pour finir sur ce
sujet le parlement européen hier soir il
a donné son feu vert un règlement qui
permet d'imposer aux plateformes le
retrait en une heure des messages des
photos des vidéos en ligne à caractère
terroriste ça sera appliqué l'année
prochaine est ce que ça vous êtes pour
mais nous on est favorable à tout ce qui
peut permettre de cibler le texte en
question je n'ai pas souvenir pas ici
mais tout ce qui peut permettre d'agir
efficacement contre le terrorisme
nous y sommes d'avoir ce qu'il faut
éviter on fait ça c'est ce qu'un jeune
oui mais ce qu'il faut éviter si le
flicage généralisé il faut faire du
ciblage c'est ça qui fonctionne à la
tentation un petit peu de poids public
et on l'avait vu avec la loi
renseignements c'est finalement de
multiplier des dispositions qui vont
restreindre les libertés tout le monde
parce qu'on n'ose pas à s'attaquer à la
petite catégorie qui pose problème dans
le journal du dimanche dimanche dernier
gérald darmanin il a dit que lors de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne ça sera au premier semestre
2001 de il engagea une réforme des
accords de schengen avec nos partenaires
européens est ce que vous la
soutiendrait cette réforme mais bon
c'est pas ce qu'il ya dans cette réforme
de schengen mais vous dites est bien
d'origine réformes dans l'éducation
remettre en cause schengen parce
qu'aujourd'hui schengen tels que ça
existe ça ne fonctionne pas enfin savons
plus tôt ça pose un énorme problème
c'est pour nous a vendus en gros c'est
simple on nous avait dit libre
circulation totale à l'intérieur mais on
protège les frontières extérieures
on a eu la libre circulation totale
intérieure l'abaissement des frontières
nationales
mais en réalité on n'a pas protégé on
s'est pas donné les moyens de protéger
quant aux réformes le constat on est
d'accord ensuite faire la proposition je
doute qu'ils remettent en cause
réellement schengen ce qu'il faut c'est
évidemment être capable de rétablir les
contrôles à l'intérieur et de se donner
les moyens de protéger nos frontières
extérieures à la fois pour que les pays
deux premiers arrivés je pense à la
grèce par exemple ou à l'espagne ne soit
pas à subir seul le le l'appui la force
de ces flux migratoires mais ça
nécessite de se donner des moyens
considère aujourd'hui c'est exactement
le contraire aujourd'hui vivant lorraine
organise l'entrée des migrants sur le
territoire européen et une fois qu'ils
sont entrés et bien on les expulse se
permet par principe vous considérez que
ce qui pourrait proposer pour cette
réforme ne niera pas dans le sens que
vous souhaitez on verra bien mais je
crains je crains que ce soit pas la
remise en cause de la libre circulation
totale qui aboutit aujourd'hui il faut
être père l'élu a sacré sur les biens
des personnes ça fait tout le monde
trouve ça très joli mais en pratique
c'est la libre circulation des armes des
trafics des théories c'est ça dont on
parle parce que au milieu des flux de
migrants donc on nous présente souvent à
tort d'ailleurs comme des pauvres
familles qui fuient la guerre
la plupart viennent pour des raisons
économiques la plupart ce sont des
hommes souvent à ces jeunes il ya très
peu de femmes et d'enfants et au milieu
et on l'a vu avec les attentats du
bataclan dans ces filières de
l'immigration et bien il ya des terol à
ceci près que la crise sanitaire en
cours fait qu'on a un regard sur les
frontières à la libre circulation des
personnes et des marchandises qui dé
facto a changé oui vous avez raison et
d'assez intéressant parce que longtemps
on nous a dit mécontent des frontières
c'est pas possible
et puis on s'est rendu compte ça a pris
du temps mais aussi rendu compte qu'avec
la crise sanitaire
eh bien on pouvait parfaitement mettre
en oeuvre des protections aux frontières
qui sont assez efficaces et d'ailleurs
ça taiko silveira blement les flux
migratoires pendant une courte période
pendant à peu près un an
ça montre qu'une une chose ça montre que
c'est possible encore faut-il en avoir
la volonté politique est justement
puisqu'on parlait de la crise sanitaire
emmanuel mâcon demain il détaillera son
plan de déconfinement dans un grand
entretien accordé à la presse
quotidienne régionale qu'est ce que vous
attendez de ce plan de déconfinement
devant je m'en inquiète un peu parce que
finalement on s'aperçoit que la loi de
sortie de crise sanitaire ça va
loi de sortie de l'état d'urgence pardon
vous dire plutôt à maintenir l'essentiel
des dispositifs existants au moins
jusqu'en octobre
et puis un régime transitoire on sort de
l'état d'urgence tel qu'on le connaît
avec un régime transitoire au cas où
l'épidémie repart c'est pas normal pour
vous non mais plus on prenne des
dispositions pour lutter contre
l'épidémie très bien mais la première
mesure à prendre c'est d'être efficace
dans la campagne de vaccination or on a
pris un retard absolument considérable
aujourd'hui elle s'apparente à un
véritable fiasco
donc on va on va demander aux français
encore des efforts on va et durera
encore les libertés individuelles
pourquoi parce que l'état et l'union
européenne accessoirement était
totalement défaillant dans cette
politique vaccinale et on a pris un
retard considérable y compris sur ceux
avec lesquels on va être en concurrence
économique dans les mois qui viennent
donc plus on a du retard sur la
vaccination
puis en soirée la réplique économie
galette véritable fiasco c'est à dire
que les objectifs 10 20 30 millions me
navre et me mets mi juin vous n'y croyez
pas alors que le lait le le premier le
premier jalon là les 10 millions de
français vaccinés au au 15 avril on dit
alors on nous avait dit il ya un an que
le royaume uni allait se mordre les
doigts quitté l'union européenne
alors quand on compare population
équivalente le royaume uni aujourd'hui
et je crois pas de 40 millions de
vaccinés la france est à 15 millions
c'est mon sang et or et amis bon donc on
voit bien on voit bien que le dispositif
européen de commande groupée avec
opacité totale opacité sur les contrats
sur les négociateurs sur les prix sur
jalle aider les délais qui ne sont pas
respectées c'est un échec complet
voilà donc il va vous vous faites
référence à astrazeneca principalement
tu vois pas seulement à l'ensemble de la
commune groupe européenne alors
finalement ça finit par arriver au
compte gouttes mais encore une fois il
ya des pays qui ont pris de l'avancé des
des pays comme le royaume uni je le cite
m et s'évader états unis c'est ma
d'israël enfin il ya beaucoup de pays
qu'on paye il avance donc dans la
compétition économique mondiale
cette avance ils vont la conserver et
donc aujourd'hui et puis je voulais
revenir sur un point important c'est que
le
la loi de sortie d'état d'urgence évoque
explicitement la question du pass
sanitaires et le hors emmanuel macron
nous avait dit à quelques mois la
vaccination ne sera pas obligatoire est
en réalité se passe sanitaire
reviendrait à la rendre obligatoire de
facto puisque ça voudrait dire que si
vous ne vous n'avez pas vous n'êtes pas
vacciné vous avez pas se passe sanitaire
beh
eh bien vous vous n'avez pas droit à une
vie sociale normale forcément la
vaccination c'est un test pcr négatif
c'est le fait que vous avez été guéri du
corps et d'un virus ça passe pas
forcément par là oui enfin c'est
essentiellement la vaccination mais ça
peut être en effet aussi de faire des
tests à chaque fois ce qui est
évidemment très contraignant mais ça
veut dire que en été on est en train
progressivement d'installer l'idée là
encore parce que c'est d'union
européenne qu'il est qu'ils exigent de
d'une vaccination obligatoire de fête
voilà donc c'est pour ça que vous êtes
opposé au pass and it est réaffirmée par
parlement européen a voté on a voté sur
la procédure d'urgence en vue de
l'adoption de ce green scientifique est
si elle le passe à une terre voilà donc
nous sommes opposés à la croisière
d'urgence là rien qui le justifie et en
effet avoir un pass anitea cissé s'il
s'agit de l'avoir pour les liaisons
aériennes par exemple pour éviter la
circulation du virus entre les pays ça
peut se concevoir et ça existe déjà pour
d'autres pointent d'autres demandes et
le contrôle des frontières notamment
bien sûr les aéroports et notamment la
fermeture de certains vols c'est pour ça
encore une fois nous n'y sommes pas
opposés pour les liaisons aériennes
mais si c'est la généralisation dans la
vie sociale au quotidien avec une
restriction des libertés absolument
dramatique et oui pires que sans passé
ni terre vous pouvez plus à leur
restaurant vous pouvais plus aller dans
les commerces
vous ne pouvez plus aller au cinéma là
ça n'est pas acceptable on va parler du
plan de relance
oui la france a présenté son plan de
relance vous lequel quel regard vous
portez sur ce sur ce plan est ce que
pour vous les efficace suffisant il faut
que là où il ya des trous dans la
raquette
il est dérisoire d'un dérisoire
dérisoire dans ses montants et ensuite
il n'est pas forcément bien orienté je
m'explique le plan de relance de
présentée par la france il est de 100
milliards avec une partie 39 milliards
qui viennent du plan de relance européen
ça vous considérez dérisoire non mais la
france et demi c'est un pib de
2200 milliards la dette publique de la
france ses 2600 milliards
et donc je veux quand même soyons clairs
et parlons un peu de chiffres nous
allons verser ces rapports du sénat qui
l'a 10 entre 70 et 80 milliards à
l'union européenne pour pouvoir toucher
ses 39 milliards et bruno le maire nous
disait on va avoir un premier versement
avant l'été le résultat c'est qu'on va
avoir un peu le premier versement en
septembre est séparée versement il sera
de 5 milliards
voilà donc en fait on va avoir dans les
mois qui viennent 5 milliards pour un
pays dont le pib 2200 mhz il ya une
dette de 2006 1 milliard bon c'est vrai
mais c'est évidemment des joies 5
milliards ces mêmes parce que là ce que
ce que l'état va injecter pour sauver
air france et le plan de relance dans
son ensemble et 100 milliards il ya
seulement 3 %
j'ai consacré aux pme voilà donc on voit
bien que ça n'est pas du tout à la
hauteur et si on veut la relance
économique
soyons clairs elle sera d'abord allié à
notre capacité à restaurer la croissance
et de la prospérité et pour restaurer la
croissance et pour rembourser nos dettes
accessoirement il faut évidemment pas
augmenter les impôts parce qu'on est
déjà un niveau confiscatoire pour ça
c'est faire une vieille femme de libérer
et protéger libérer c'est à dire alléger
la fiscalité les contraintes qui pèsent
sur les entreprises les normes notamment
environnementales qui sont des coûts
supplémentaires pour nos entreprises
pour nos industries pour les
agriculteurs voilà et d'autre part si
crée donc créer les conditions de la
compétitivité économique
et si ça n'est pas suffisant et qu'il ya
des situations de concurrence déloyale
être capable de protéger celle des
droits de douane des quotas ou des
contingentements sur un certain nombre
de produits c'est ce que font tous les
pays du monde
aujourd'hui on a contraire on a une
fiscalité très forte des normes
juridiques très lourde qui brident
l'activité économique est par ailleurs
un libre échange généralisé aucune
protection économique
c'est ça qui a goûté une situation qui
nous empêche de nous relever
économiquement on va passer au reste de
l'actualité
nicolas b c notamment cette tribune des
militaires dans valeurs actuelles un qui
a fait beaucoup de bruit marie le pen
elle a soutenu cette tribune des
militaires qui menacent d'intervenir
face au chaos croissant pas tout à fait
ils disent qu'ils craignent que l'armée
soit appelé à intervenir mais par les
pouvoirs publics évidemment on va
écouter ce qu'on a dit jean castex hier
de cette tribune et du soutien que
marine le pen lui apporter ce pourrait
donc être une affaire insignifiante
s'il n'y avait pas une récupération
politique je le dis tout à fait
inacceptable comment des gens et madame
le pen en particulier qui aspirent à
exercer responsabilité de l'état
peut-elle cautionner une initiative qui
n'exclut pas de se retourner contre
l'état républicain qu'est ce que vous
répondez un saint ni contre mais c'est
totalement mensonger jean castex dit
n'importe quoi
qu'est ce que c'est militer à dix ils
ont connu pour beaucoup d'entre eux des
situations de conflit des opérations
extérieures des pays où c'était le chaos
au mât lire l'organiste ans ou même
donc ils sont conscients de ce que je
peux être le chaos dans un pays il y
simplement que l'armée risque d'être
appelé par les pouvoirs publics c'est de
ça dont il s'agit
si jamais la ici on est à une situation
de désordre total c'est gérard collomb
lui même qui quittant la place beauvau a
dit demain risque d'être face à face
donc il ya un moyen il ya une
malhonnêteté intellectuelle de la part
du premier ministre et un manque de
lucidité total et quand je vois ce matin
le général lecointe chef d'état major
des armées qui annonce des sanctions
contre ceux qui se sera affranchie d'un
devoir de réserve alors que lui même
dans la même interview s'affranchit
totalement de son devoir de réserve il
le fait sans doute sur instruction de
l'elysée en mai s'affranchit de son
label il critique ouvertement je cite
les femmes et les hommes politiques qui
aujourd'hui instrumentalise l'armée etc
il fait de la politique monsieur
lecointe alors qu'il est chef
d'état-major des armées qu'il est non
seulement en activité mais non
responsabilité et à et dans le même
temps il explique que les généraux
deuxième section dieu ne sont plus en
service actif et bien font l'objet de
sanctions parce qu'ils se sont à
franchir leur devoir de réserve mais
c'est absolument incroyable à la fois
d'incohérences et de et de légèreté
voilà donc moi je dis simplement que le
général lecointe à mieux
d'écouter les militaires d'écouter les
militaires de terrain qui s'inquiètent
de la cide légitimement de la situation
du pays et puis on pourrait leur être
filmé un petit peu de respect parce que
ces militaires qui ont se sont mis au
service de notre pays et qui ont été
loin puisqu'ils ont été jusqu'à jusqu'à
prendre le risque de perdre la vie
quand il était dans des théâtres
d'opérations extérieures il mériterait
un tout petit peu de respect de
considération de la part du gouvernement
plutôt que d'avoir les propos méprisants
de madame manière une hache et dont on
voit bien qu'elle connaît rien au sujet
et que et qu'elle s'exprime chez les
sujets voilà avec une légèreté
incroyable exclusivement l'extrait
convient de voir le jean castex ne
parlait pas de la tribune par des de
l'attitude de marine le pen et par
rapport à l'appel a simplement dit que
ses militaires avaient raison de
s'inquiéter
elle est dans son rôle politique on a
quand même le limiter à 10 on est
arrivés à la situation de délitement de
l'état et de la nation avec des
situation est très grave et un
gouvernement qui n'est pas à la hauteur
ça correspond à exactement une autre
analyse pouvait 99,9 pour cent des
signataires sont des militaires
retraités si j'ai bien compris donc ils
n'ont ils ne sont plus contraints par le
devoir de réserve
voilà et les autres c'est des généraux
deuxième section c'est qu'ils ne sont
plus en service actif
voilà mais nous nous faisons de la
politique et nous essayons d'apporter
une réponse politique
nous pensons que ce chaos et ce
délitement de l'état elle n'est pas
inéluctable donc c'est bien normal que
marine le pen comme candidate à la
présidentielle et principal adversaire
des madones bacrot est bien dit ce
qu'elle tient compte parfaitement elle
tient compte bien sûr à elle dans son
analyse et dans son projet politique de
cette préoccupation légitime des
militaires et d'ailleurs ce qu'ils
expriment c'est finalement d'une
certaine manière un petit peu ce
qu'avait exprimé le général pierre de
villiers parce qu il
ils avaient été envoyés dès le début du
quinquennat des modèles macro simplement
parce qu'il avait bien un certain nombre
de vérités sur la situation du pays et
sur le manque de moyens des forces
armées le parlement européen je passais
un tout autre sujet a approuvé l'accord
commercial conclu par l'union européenne
avec le royaume uni
adacore que vous avez vous même à
prouver et qui sort gagnant de ce break
site à votre sens
est ce qu'il aura pas les conséquences
compliqué pour votre région en normandie
je suis à sa maquette beaucoup j'étais
aux côtés des pêcheurs normands
il ya quelques jours et justement il
s'estime lisent ils sont inquiets les
situations ils ont un pied de manière
générale d'ailleurs des décisions
souvent unilatérales qui sont prises par
la commission européenne
ils sont inquiets parce que la pêche
française a été passée par pertes et
profits dans la négociation sur le bike
site puisque ça a été traité à l'arrêt
dû être central et ça a été traitée à la
va-vite en quinze jours au dernier
moment alors qu'on était sous la menace
d'un odile c'est-à-dire digne d'une
absence d'accord
ça a été totalement évacué pourquoi
parce que beaucoup de pays se moquait
éperdument de la pêche française et donc
c'est un prop sun les lames sont gérés
quand même battu donc normalement
français s'est battu pour les méchants
djouba on n'a rien vu de très concret
aux étoiles française est fragilisée en
normandie c'est 24 mille emplois directs
et indirects
c'est une filière à la fois économiques
importantes et aussi une filière
d'excellence alors sur le maxi de magna
plus les engins qui traînent beaucoup
les pieds qui l'utilisent de manoeuvres
dilatoires
n'empêche que leur valeur de marché mais
quelle a été l'attitude des institutions
européennes au début il ya cinquante
quasiment maintenant quand ils ont vu
quand les britanniques ont voté pour
sortir l'union européenne tout a été
fait pour essayer de remettre en cause
ce vote d'échapper aux makes it de
repasser les plats en quelque sorte et
certains échafauder des plans dans ce
sens et pino disait il ne frappe unir
les britanniques pour pour pour que pour
qu'il paye cher le fait de sortir
l'union rebelles et puis ensuite boris
johnson a gagné les élections
donc le mexique est devenu inéluctable
avec puisqu'il avait le soutien
populaire renouvelé pour mener à bien
les négociations et hélas l'union
européenne a tout lâché la commission
européenne a tout lâché puisque les
britanniques voulaient tuer résume un
accès total au marché européen sans sans
avoir à appliquer le droit européen et
les jeux et danses de cour européenne de
la cua de justice de l'union
ils ont absolument tout obtenu c'est à
dire qu'ils apportent la démonstration
pour peut avoir en gros tous les
avantages sans les inconvénients et une
dernière question de ses fans sur les
régionales sur les régionales
comment comment est ce que vous voyez
les choses comme on se coule ou est-ce
que vous laissiez des sondages vous
situer aujourd'hui et quel est votre
degré de confiance par rapport à cette
élection
d'un côté c'est toute la difficulté ça
va être de la mobilisation je pense qu
il ya un risque c'est l'abstention
et moi je vous dis à nos compatriotes
ils ont l'occasion de voter c'est la
première fois qu'ils ont eu l'occasion
de voter depuis
début de la crise sanitaire on est à un
an de l'élection présidentielle c'est
évidemment une élection régionale sur
les enjeux régionaux mais d'abord
peut-être une élection à très grande
dimension politique et c'est l'occasion
d'envoyer un message au gouvernement
osez face aux échelles des modèles macro
et de son gouvernement est aussi un
message à tous ceux qui est je pense
notamment au président de région sortant
centriste ou de centre droit comme hervé
morin en normandie comme un au muesli en
paca et d'autre et bien leur envoyer un
signal
voilà ils ne veulent pas non plus de
cette espèce de fausse droite qui s'est
mobilisé autour d'un vote protestataire
vous n'avez pas un projet déjà bien sûr
j'ai un projet par les hommes ont dit
que je développe tous les jours je fais
quand même quand même je me mets pas les
assemblées en fait l'enjeu politique de
ces jeunes en général mais moi en
normandie je pense qu'il faut
prioritairement développer les
infrastructures routières ferroviaires
en particulier et portuaire pour donner
de l'attractivité économique et il faut
ne gestion plus rigoureuse de l'argent
public avait morin s'était engagé sur 50
millions de belges les dépenses de
fonctionnement pour accroître
l'investissement et bien résultat on a
300 millions de hausse des dépenses de
fonctionnement par an c'est à dire ça
représente quand même des sommes
considérables sur un mandat de cadu est
presque plus de cinq ans et ça a
évidemment ça au balo capacité
d'investissement voilà enfin j'aurai
l'occasion de développer tout au long de
la campagne
mon projet pour la normandie pour
redonner sa son rayonnement à la
normandie et sa force
mais d'une manière générale le
rassemblement national a pour objectif
pour ces régionales de gagner des
régions parce que je pense que c'est
possible et qu'il y a à la fois que j'ai
des manades m'apprend et son
gouvernement et du bilan de beaucoup de
présidents de région sortants et on va
parler des régionales dans quelques
instants dans le club avant ça regarde
la une de ouest france déclaration de
revenus tout ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
à la une de votre journal stéphane merci
stéphane bern et merci beaucoup ne pas
la gâcher vous
[Musique]